did you know that in Australia the air
pods to with the wireless charging case
cost three hundred and twenty dollars
today we're going to take a look at
these little beasts to find out if
they're worth that much money what's
going on guys my name is David Tommy and
welcome back to the channel thankfully
since my last video I've gotten a little
bit better and I don't need a cup of tea
with me to talk about the air pods -
today we're going to look at the airport
- in depth we're going to take a look at
the wireless charging case and the
differences between the air pods one and
the air pods two themselves right now
without looking at the facts I
personally think that you shouldn't be
upgrading but let's take a look at all
the facts the specs and the differences
between the two and see if it's worth
the extra money okay so I'm going to
keep myself centered in the screen here
today and drop a list down on the right
hand side about the air pods one and
drop a list on the left hand side about
the air pods - let's take a quick
comparison between these two and find
out what's actually changed so straight
off the top of the bat if we look at the
design the design has stayed exactly the
same the only difference between the one
and the two is the wireless charging
case which has a small small small
little LED at the front of the case that
you can tell it apart but when you
actually look at the inside of the
headphones and the actual design of the
headphones themselves not a single thing
has changed between the one and twos now
let's talk about performance if you're
talking on the phone with these in your
ears with the air pods one you're gonna
get about two hours battery life on the
air pods - you're gonna get three hours
which is actually a pretty good increase
from generation to generation if you're
listening to music however they're both
exactly the same coming in at a five
hours of total playtime I think it
probably doesn't matter to you guys or
to me really is the fact that the chips
upgraded the chip itself in the air pods
one is a w1 chip whilst in the air pods
- it's an h1 chip now the difference
here isn't that great apple says it
gives you about 50% quicker increases in
switching between devices and things
like that but the actual sound quality
has remained exactly the same one added
benefit of this airport
so is the fact that you no longer have
to DoubleTap to activate Siri series now
always listening to conversations and
can pick up when you say the magic words
and get it to activate via your voice
great little feature if you're on the
run or if your hands are full but
otherwise just another nifty trick so if
you want to buy the wireless case and
all on its own if you have the air pods
one for example it's gonna cost you a
hundred and thirty Australian dollars
and if for some strange reason you just
want the headphones and not the charging
case for the second generation maybe
you've lost your set and still have the
charging case well that's still going to
cost you an extra two hundred and fifty
dollars just to replace the headphones
themselves one con with the wireless
charging case unfortunately is the fact
that it doesn't support wireless charge
sharing unlike the review I did at the
Samsung buds last week I'm gonna put a
little information thing if I remember
up above so you can check that video out
too you can't just tap it on top of your
phone and it starts charging but you can
drop it on to any charging map and it
will wirelessly charge which for some
people might be a great feature for
other people not so much now some people
have come out and said that the audio
quality is a little bit better and
others have come out flat out saying no
that it's definitely not better it's
pretty much identical I've gone ahead
and tested the air pods - in the air
pods one in my spare time away from here
because I don't have both generations on
me now and I can honestly say the sound
is almost identical so if you're looking
to upgrade just because of the sound
quality unfortunately that's a little
bit of a disappointment for you guys
today because the sound quality is
exactly the same as the air pods one so
now if we really think about the
differences between the air pods one and
the air pods - well really
besides the talktime there isn't that
many different features to justify
spending three hundred and twenty
dollars on a wireless charging case with
the air pods - versus I believe a two
hundred and fifty dollars that they were
when they first came out as the air pods
one or you can still buy actually the
airports - without the charging case for
$250 well I don't know about you guys
but I really wouldn't be going out and
spending the extra hundred dollars to
upgrade to a wireless charging case
especially if you don't have a wireless
charging pad if you do have a nice
little Apple wireless charging
can mount three different things on it
for example like your iPhone yeah I
watch and potentially your earpods
then I don't know maybe that might be
worth the upgrade
however from standpoint alone of just a
wireless feature I don't know in my
personal opinion definitely not worth
the upgrade definitely worth still
getting the air pods one considering the
quality and the price difference and
that's it from me today guys if you
enjoyed the air pods to review make sure
you drop a comment down below let me
know what you thought like always
smash that subscribe button 20:19 style
and I'll see you next Monday
you